and this usually means that they're
looking for Consultants who already
worked on similar topics in the past so
this is like one very big requirement
that's usually there so what does this
mean to you well if you're a consultant
you want to do a specific project if you
have already done related things in the
past this will really help you then to
do more things in that direction so
usually just getting the foot in the
door with a new type of projects and
your industry and your function is the
most important one after you've done
that a couple of times and made a name
for yourself it will be much much easier
going forward to do more project and
Direction but then the other second
important one is also they're looking
for Consultants that are just High
performers Consultants that have a
reputation of being rock stars of being
those that just really always deliver
are always doing a great job